حيث قال جوزيف بوريل مفوض السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي ان الوضع في
تونس سيئ للغايه اقتصاديا وسياسيا واضاف
فوريلا انطلاق اجتماع وزراء خارجيه
الاتحاد في بروكسل ان عدم الاستقرار
السياسي في تونس يؤثر على الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه فيها وكشف ان الاجتماع سيناقش
ما سماها تصريحات غير المقبوله تجاهها
جنسيه افريقيه والتي صدرت عن الرئيس
التونسي قيس سعيد لافتا الى انه قد يسافر
الى تونس اذا تطلب الامر
انه وضع اقتصادي وسياسي مؤلم تواجه تونس
وضعا يترافق فيه عدم الاستقرار السياسي مع
وضع اقتصادي مزر لا يمكن ان يؤدي الى
اتفاق مع صندوق النقد الدولي بالاضافه الى
ذلك فهنالك تصريحات غير المقبوله بشان
المهاجرين من جنوب الصحراء الكبرى سنناقش
كيف يمكننا ان نساعد تونس اليوم اعتقد انه
ربما يتعين علينا السفر الى تونس ولكن
دعونا نرى اولا ما هو موقف الوزراء اليوم
وفي العاصمه التونسيه نفذ حركه 25 من
يوليو المساند لرئيس قيس سعيد مظاهره
بمناسبه عيد الاستقلال تعبيرا عن مساندته
للرئيس في مساره السياسي الحالي رفع
المشاركون خلال المظاهره شعارات ترفض ما
سموه التدخل الاجنبي في شؤون البلاد متمنه
خطوات الرئيس قيس سعيد في هذا الاطار
[تصفيق]
معنى الان من مدينه سوسه شرق تونس قيصر
الصياح المحامي والباحث في القانون ومن
تونس ايضا خالد البارودي الكاتب الصحفي
والمحلل السياسي ارحب بكم ما هو ابدا معك
استاذ قيصر صياح الوضع في تونس سيء للغايه
اقتصاديا
وسياسيا هذا ما يقوله مفوض السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي تعليقكم على
ذلك
شكرا مساء الخير الوضع كان سيء ولا يزال
الى حد الان سيء نتيجه ما تعلق به من
تعثرات ومن مطبات خلال سنوات طوال والوضع
يتجه الى تحسن الان باعتبار ان الدوله
بصداد القيام بكل الاجراءات اللازمه على
المستوى السياسي والاجتماعي والاقتصادي
لتسويق هذه الازمه والمرور بالبلاد الى
مرحله الامان خاصه ان الدوله الان قد قامت
بواجبها على الاقل خلال هاته الامواج وهذه
الطلاقات السياسيه والاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه المتراكمه منذ سنين والتي ادت
الى عجز ميزان تجاري 42 الف مليار منذ سنه
2018 عقاب القيس سعيد نفسه و 110 الف
مليار تقريبا منذ 2017 وهو ما يوازي ثلاثه
مرات ميزانيه تونس الان دعني اقول انا
الوضع يتجه الى التحرر على الاقل على
مستوى تسويه الوضع وتركيز المؤسسات وخاصه
المؤسسه التشريعيه والتي هي المؤسسه
الاعلى وهي عرب التشريع في تونس
وباستقلالها تنتهي مرحله جدا باستكمال
السلطات الثلاث على الاقل باعتبار وجود
الان المرفق القضائي بشكل المجلس الاعلى
للقضاء المؤقت والذي هو عباره عن ضمانه مع
المحكمه الاداريه التي تراقب الاحكام في
انتظار صدور او وجود
قانون هيكل محكمه
في هذا النقاش يعني كما تقول الوضع لا
يزال سيء اقتصاديا وسياسيا الا ان هناك
جوانب يراها ايجابيه في هذه المرحله سيد
البارودي كيف تابعتم تصريحات الاوروبيه
المتعلقه بتونس وما الدور الذي يمكن
للاتحاد الاوروبي ان يلعبه في هذه المرحله
نعم مساء الخير في الحقيقه تضر ما يتحدث
عنها اتحاد الاوروبي وكثير من النوابه
ورئيسه مساله خطيره جدا وربما شكل تصعيدي
لاول مره تصل البلاد الى هذا المنعطف
اعتقد انه منعطف حاد جدا وخطير جدا ويجب
ان ينظر اليه بالانتباه المطلوب تونس وقعت
اتفاق شراكه مع الاتحاد الاوروبي منذ
التسعينات وفي هذا الموضوع تونس تحتاج الى
هذا الملف تونس تحتاج الى شراكه مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي نظرا لان هناك تبادل
تجاري كثيف مع الاتحاد الاوروبي وهناك
الاجراءات او ربما امتيازات كثيره جبائيه
تتمتع بها تونس تفاضليا يتيح لها
ان تكون في موضع جيد على مستوى التبادل
التجاري الاتحاد الاوروبي امضى هذا
الاتفاق من الكثيره على اشتراطات كثيره
هذه الاشتراطات تتعلق بالوضع الديمقراطي
في البلاد بوضع الحريات بوضع حريه التعبير
واحترام الصحافه وللاسف الشديد النقطه
الاخيره ايضا نقطه ضبط الحدود كل هذه
النقاط بدات الان فيها كثير من الاشكاليات
وفيها كثير منها
الاتحاد الاوروبي اصبحت مهدده الاستاذ
قيصر الى اي مدى تتشارك مع السيد البارودي
في هذا الراي الشراكه التونسيه مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي في الملفات الاقتصاديه اصبحت
مهدده اليوم بسبب ملفات اخرى تتعلق بحريه
التعبير الصحافه وما الى ذلك
لا ليس صحيح لا يشارك مطلقا هذا الراي
باعتبار ان تونس شريك مميز الاتحاد
الاوروبي وعلاقات الاتحاد الاوروبي
استثماريا واقتصاديا وماليا مع الخزينه
العامه للدوله ومع الصادرات تونس تعتبر
تقريبا هي الاولى الدوله الاولى المصدره
لفرنسا الان ولا يمكن القول بهذا الامر
باعتبار انا مجرد
فقيه ومن شرا
كه تونس الاتحاد الاوروبي يعني هو انهيار
كامل للعلاقه الاستراتيجيه والجيوسيه مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي وهو كلام مردود على
قائله بخصوص النقطه الثانيه المتعلقه
بمساله
الذر الذي قد يحصل لتونس نتيجه ما يسمى
بنقاط الحدود او العبور هذه مساله واضحه
جدا يعرفها القاسي والداني تتعلق برغبه
الجامحه في كبح الجماع المهاجرين ومنحهم
من العبور الى الاتحاد الاوروبي وهي
بطبيعه الحال مصلحه عليا للاتحاد الاوروبي
وبالتالي فان النقاش على مستوى التوازن
التحليلي السياسي هو نقاش ذو ابعاد مصلحيه
مطلقه ولا علاقه له باستقرار تونس باعتبار
الاتحاد الاوروبي لو كان يريد اعاده تونس
الان اقل في رفع المديونيه عنها وفي دعمها
اقتصاديا باعتبارها شريك مميز باعلان رسمي
اوروبي منذ تقريبا 15 سنه ثم في نقاط اخرى
اريد ان اعرج على نقطه هامه واساسيه
جاهده تونس في سبتمبر 2021 وقبل الرئيس
قيس سعيد وقابل الهيئه السياسيه وقال
الخطوه وانا متفائل بل المرور الا انا
وكذلك
[موسيقى]
الاتحاد الاوروبي وقال نحن نتقاسم نفس
القيم والحقوق معك
كما يقول ضيف
نعم
للاسف الشديد طول خرقت كثير من الاتفاقيات
كما قلنا الاتفاقيات تتعلق بحقوق الانسان
وحريه التعبير وكلها للاعتقالات التي
نراها الان هي من صميم هذا الموضوع ايضا
الانغلاق السياسي والاجتماعي الذي تشهده
البلاد ايضا عامل اساسي جعل الاتحاد
الاوروبي يراجع ربما او يفكر في مراجعه
وضع تونس كم بلد مميز او علاقات مميزه
ايضا مثل ضبط الحدود كان على تونس ان تقوم
بجهود اكثر وضوح واكثر مصداقيه نرى ان
مئات التونسيين والاجانب يسافرون عبر
الارض التونسيه للاسف الشديد
ومساله التصدي للهجره الافريقيه الى تونس
اخذت بطريقه خاطئه وتتم اخراجها من
وظيفتها الحقيقيه على اساس ان هناك اشكال
صحيح ولكن لا يعالج على اساس انه مؤامره
دوليه وان هناك من يحيك شيئا مالي تونس
كان هناك خطا اتصالي في هذا الملف ومما
جعل من تونس بلد ينعت بالعنصريه وهو بعيد
جدا عن هذا الامر كل هذه المسائل
الاجتماعيه الاقتصاديه والسياسيه طبعا
اتخذ منها اتحاد الاوروبي موقفا ولا بد
انه قد يصل حتى الى العقوبات على تونس او
الحصار على تونس وهذا ما نخش وهذا ما احد
لكم خالد البارودي الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل
السياسي من تونس شكرا لك شكرا موصول ايضا
لقيصر الصياح المحامي والباحث في القانون
كان معنا من مدينه سوسه